[Music]
foreign
to you you're watching the Press preview
of first look at what's on the front
pages as they arrive here at the Sky
News Center it's time to see what's
making the headlines tonight we have
Nancy Fielder the editor-in-chief at the
national world studies newspaper group
we're also joined by Lucy Fisher White
tour editor at the financial times
ladies thank you so much for joining me
tonight back to you in just a few
minutes let's firstly start off by
having a look at what's on the front
pages of tomorrow's papers and as the
eve of the coronation approaches the
Metro Pictures The Prince and Princess
of Wales drinking pints in a pub with
the headlines send him hick torius the
telegraph focuses on the coronation
Anthem composed by Andrew Lloyd Webber
which he says he hopes will be sung in
churches across the land the male
meanwhile leads with what it calls
growing anger over the attendance at the
ceremony of China's vice president
on the day Oil Company shall announced
record profits of 32 billion pounds the
I newspaper reports that it force-fitted
4 000 of those controversial prepayment
meters in less well-off households in
the same period
the possible dangers of artificial
intelligence lead the guardian tomorrow
morning with fresh warnings from
technology Watchdogs here and in the
United States about its continued
development
the financial times leads with the
latest interest rate Rise by the
European Central Bank and a warning from
its president that the fight against
inflation isn't over yet and a quick
reminder of course for you that by
scanning the QR code that you're going
to see on screen during your program
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch it with us well let's talk now
to our paper previewers we're joined
tonight of course by Nancy Fielder and
Lucy Fisher thank you so much for
staying up way past your bedtime to talk
to us this evening
um let's start with the front page of
the Ft voters Vex by photo IDs of course
today it has been the local elections
the first elections in this country
where it has been mandatory to bring
some form of ID in it certainly from
reading the newspaper reports it seems
like it's been mixed success Nancy to
you first what do you make about the 80
have covered it and the story in general
I think the ft's got it spot on with
this one everything we're hearing from
readers and everybody will speak to all
the comments we get online is that
nobody is really quite sure why you need
to bring photo ID at this point it
didn't seem like of all the big
electronic scams going on this doesn't
seem like it was one of them
turnout we know is going to be really
low people's mobile is Rock Bottom
without politicians and this is just
another step that's putting people off
voting and sadly I think it will have an
impact we haven't had many stories of
people who've actually been turned away
because I think the message did get
across fairly well fairly loud and clear
but it's just another hurdle that's been
putting away in the way of a country
that's really fed up with its
politicians anyway I suppose losing we
have to have ID on many other forms of
our life don't we in day-to-day life so
what what difference does it make when
we have to go and vote
well I think that is the argument that's
been mounted by ministers who also point
out it is the norm at polling stations
across much of Europe and other
democracies as well I think the
criticism perhaps has been about the
speed at which this has been brought in
and the list of ID documents that have
been accepted there's 22 forms of ID
that have been eligible to show our
polling stations today ranging from
passport to driving license to biometric
immigration documentation but there's
also been a criticism that a a wider
array of travel passes eligible for
older citizens have been accepted
whereas um similar travel passes for
younger people and haven't been on that
list
um I haven't been uh noted and been
concerned that the Electoral reform
society which has been against this
change today has said that there have
been examples both of people turning up
at polling stations with the wrong type
of ID but also people turning up with
photo identification and being told by
returning return officers and officials
in polling stations that they don't look
enough like the photo in their ID and
therefore again not being able to vote
yeah okay let's move on and have a look
at the I newspaper shell making a 32
billion pound profit I wanted to say the
least particularly in the current
climate and then there's a catch as well
isn't there Nancy how do you read this
what does it say
I mean yeah this is a great front page
on the day that shell announces that
it's made billions who are all these
people who were forced to have prepay
meters put into their homes because they
basically couldn't be trusted to pay
their bills now the reason for that is
because they didn't have enough money
the great irony with the prepay meters
is all of a sudden the various poorest
people in our country were forced to pay
premium rates because of the meters and
they had no choice
and for Shell to be doing that while
they are literally making billions in
profits I mean this was this is the
whole heat or eat debate people were
having to make that choice it really
really cold periods where they were
worried about feeding their families
food banks have absolutely soared in the
last few years
I mean it's disgusting and it show the
big oil companies just rake it in they
don't seem to care nothing seems to
bother them the government doesn't seem
to take much action on it and I think
you just got to feel for the people who
were sort of forced into this and it
doesn't really feel like a massive
amount has changed the gap's just
growing isn't it between the those who
have and those who have not
back to the front page of the eye
newspaper talking about their big story
being shell making billions of pounds of
property uh profit I should say but
they're going with the line that they
have Force fitted 4 000 prepayment
meters in the UK while making this
amount of profit I mean they say that
the installations are a last resort and
its UK division is loss making what do
you make of that line
well that's obvious well that's
obviously um Shell's uh defense
um of these figures but also a very um
striking comparison that the eye
newspaper has brought out saying that
the record
um uh profits that shell has made 32
billion pounds has meant that it has
been able to pay out to its shareholders
more money than the entire sum that the
UK treasury has raked in so far from its
windfall tax on oil and gas so I think
we're only going to see renewed pressure
now from opposition parties on the
government to extend that windfall tax
to try and reap in um more of these sort
of extraordinary profits that fossil
fuel companies are making in order to
try and bring down the price of energy
for consumers will that happen do you
think Nancy there is a windfall tax in
place already do you think the
government will expand it definitely
something that the labor would want to
do isn't it
it may depend on what happens in the
early hours of today and when the
results come back in tomorrow I mean the
conservative government don't seem very
keen on it they throw every excuse they
can as to why they shouldn't um tax
these multi-billion pound profit
organizations more but I think your
average person on the street thinks that
you should pay more that everybody has
to pay you you pay depending on how much
you earn so surely that could be
extended and particularly when you're
looking at the great iron in this story
and how people at the very bottom are
the ones who've been punished more I
think it could well become a big
election debate but we will see after
the election that we've just finished
today let's get back to the financial
times and talk about another business
related program that uh story I should
say that regarding uh inflation we had
the European Central Bank didn't we
raising interest rates and also warning
that fight against inflation isn't over
so a stark warning for all of us that
you know the cost of living crisis isn't
going away anytime soon is it Lucy
no that's right and the ECB raising at
The Benchmark rate by uh 25
percentage uh 25 basis points today it
is a slower rate than they have raised
The Benchmark rate in the past and they
note that there are you know fears of a
credit Crunch and the borrowing has
reached um borrowings in a restrictive
territory now which are the factors that
have influenced this slight slows down
in the rate going up but they warned
that if this isn't the loss we're likely
to see of Rises this year that expect
the Benchmark rate to reach 3.75 in July
of course this comes uh after the U.S
federal reserve also raised rates
um earlier this week so yes inflation is
remaining stubbornly High across both
sides of the Atlantic and central banks
are struggling to do what they can to
try and curb it
I'm just reading a little bit further
into the article Nancy it says that the
the U.S federal reserve of course that's
the US's Central Bank signal this week
There's a its latest quarter point rate
rise could be its last so maybe a bit of
a silver lining and I wonder what that
will mean maybe for for our Central Bank
the bank of England whether we think
that interest rates in this country have
kind of leveled off what do you think
what are your reasons
and I mean the interest rate that we're
talking about the rise is actually
smaller than many had feared it would be
so I mean all the signs are there that
it is easing off but I think that the
problem is it's a long way from being
over isn't it and I think people have
kind of survived winter they've got
through the enormous
bills they haven't they may not have all
arrived at the enormous bills but I
think it's kind of you feel that there
might be a bit of a relief coming but
yeah actually when when you speak to
people they are still really worried
about paying for their mortgages there's
lots of people's mortgages haven't
changed because they're on deals yet and
when that comes out absolutely terrified
what's going to happen so even if it
slows down or even if it studies where
it is it's it's still a nightmare
situation for your average Ordinary
Family
um let's have a look at some of the
other stories that you've chosen for us
to have a look at now starting with the
front page of the Daily Mail they're
looking ahead of course to the
coronation on Saturday and the guest
list and they're saying mounting
excitement ahead the coronation last
night has been overshadowed by a furious
round about China's involvement in the
historic occasion tell us more Lucy
well this is the news that instead of
the Chinese president Xi Jinping
accepting the invitation to the
coronation he is sending the vice
president Han Jiang now this is the
Chinese politician who has overseen the
brutal Crackdown on Liberties in Hong
Kong which has been a key source of
geopolitical tensions between the UK and
China it's led to a home office scheme
allowing
um certain citizens of Hong Kong who
helped passports or British overseas
nationality to come and live in the UK
um and so it seems a slightly odd Choice
it's certainly being interpreted as a
snub by the likes of Chris Patton Lord
Patton the UK's last Governor of Hong
Kong who says that the decision to send
Han Chang shows that China doesn't give
as he describes it to who's about the UK
yeah absolutely
um what do you make of this then Nancy
in terms of I mean I suppose it would
you expect the president of China to
come or do you I mean the vice president
some people would say is more than
enough
I think it depends where you sit in how
much you think this combination is a
massive thing and how important the
British royal family is these days I
mean I don't think it shows that they
don't give two Hoots I think it shows
that they're actually playing quite a
game and they're using the coronation as
a political tool is what it looks like
to a lot of people I mean the male says
it will it's sort of overshadowing
things it may be in sort of certain
political Arenas I think for your
average person who's planning um on
enjoying the street parties I don't
think it's a big thing at all but it
clearly is sending a message this is not
an accidental thing is it they've
they've picked who they're sending and
it's somebody that they know will
deliberately cause a stir so it will be
interesting to hear the conversations
that perhaps won't be held in public and
certain doesn't help that the relations
does it right now between China and the
UK okay let's have a look at what else
is in the papers the Guardians front
page warning again are the dangers of AI
this is as the news it broke yesterday
that one of the seniors of Google has
quit saying that development of AI has
just gone too far what's the Guardians
take this time Nancy let's come back to
you first
so this is the fact that the British
Watchdog and also in America they are
kind of stepping up now and saying
actually we found a bit of a warning
blow here that we are watching AI there
may well be tight regulations and
actually the industry should get itself
in order and make sure that everything
is safe that these are that they're not
spreading misinformation when it comes
to journalism being done by AI that cars
are safe and we're not killing people
when it comes to cars being driven by AI
so it just covers so many different
aspects of all our lives and although
some of the big ones are coming to the
front now actually AI has been in the
background for a very very long time so
it is about time we got a little bit of
control on this I'm not quite sure we're
gonna get control over it but we do need
regulations in place and we do need to
know that these things aren't been
rolled out so quickly it can take over
and create Havoc which some of them have
the possibility of doing this so massive
and they spread so quickly okay Lucy
just quickly um give us your opinion on
this before I ask you we move on to
another paper I mean do you share those
concerns that no the Nazi has
yeah look I think Nazi makes a good
point at the moment the expertise behind
the coding um to make these models these
so-called foundational tools of AI
um are located within um companies
private uh corporations and also the
enormous amount of computing power
that's needed to power these models
again is held in the past in the hands
of private companies so I think given
that there are such a huge consequences
for society when it comes to all sorts
of fields whether it's disinformation
and what people can believe as
um deep fakes become ever more lifelike
as uh chat Bots like chat gbt become
ever more sophisticated and indeed the
impact on jobs there's now a lot of
concern about how many sectors are going
to be completely disrupted by AI being
able to do the jobs that are currently
performed by humans I think there does
need to be
um you know a much more grip taken by
governments and and regulation begin to
be thought about in a much more serious
and comprehensive way okay Nancy and
Lucy will be looking at more papers
including the front page the Metro sent
him Victorious it's a fantastic
headliner in the next hour for now they
thank you very much of course Nancy Lucy